let's get back to the phones at 6 1 7 8
3 0 47 50 you know who has not called in
for 10 months it's been 10 months since
we caught him live it's furious trumpets
Jimmy from Philly let's see what's going
on with Jimmy Jimmy it was September
24th the last time you called him are
you in a welding facility yeah yeah
hey Jimmy please please don't scream
into the phone it's very unpleasant yeah
please that nice guy like that nice
quiet calm Jimmy boy Jimmy Jimmy I wanna
I don't want to miss a second of what
you're saying you're so loud you've got
to move the phone like a foot from your
mouth okay you've got to move it like
literally the closet is away yeah I work
around machinery I get so black lives
matter you don't like okay what lies
that and so this relates to what do you
know what are you talking I don't know
what you're talking about so you don't
like black lives matter some kind of
racial pride okay all right and is Jimmy
is black lives matter
a racial pride group or is it a race I
saw I saw a bunch of kids with no masks
at the anti mask anti lockdown protests
- no but hold on a second Jimmy cuz now
you're saying something different you
you said black lives matter is bad
because you saw kids at the protests but
what about the kids that the anti masks
protests are you worried about that
you're not and why'd you get a warm
fuzzy feeling from the armed anti-mask
protesters intimidating law enforcement
sorry what okay but so did you get it
but the question was did you get a warm
fuzzy feeling from it are you on a
riding mower right now all right Jimmy
very good well it sounds like everything
are you off alcohol and on LSD distiller
yeah yeah ridiculous that is sorry I
shadow band yeah what is that all right
Jimmy we're gonna let him go
when Jimmy starts going homophobic we do
let him go let's see who and what a
connection
let me tell you real quick about one of
our sponsors cuts clothing they offer
super quality men's t-shirts and they're
giving you 15% off when you go to david
pakman.com slash cuts that see UTS
because solid color t-shirts are a
really important staple in pretty much
every guy's wardrobe I think it's really
important not to overlook the value of
having t-shirts you love wearing
t-shirts from cuts clothing have been a
game changer for me and as a company all
they deal with are men's
solid color t-shirts so they actually
put a ton of thought into the comfort
the style the durability of the t-shirts
they make they fit perfectly they're not
scratchy they don't shrink they don't
fade they don't stretch out over time
like so many other t-shirts they're
really the most comfortable t-shirts
I've owned and they look great this
right here that I'm wearing on YouTube
is the split hem crew neck t-shirt very
soft fits me perfectly it's the ideal
length go take a look at what they offer
and once you have it you are really
going to see and feel the difference
their slogan is it's the only shirt
worth wearing you will see why and
you'll get 15% off when you do it by
going to david pakman.com slash cuts
that's david pakman.com slash c UTS